sherita's down-home style should be a
unique selling point but it ain't
working I need to go back to the kitchen
and find out why Friday and should we
just tackle in most of the day's
preparations single-handedly in a
desperate bid to save money part of this
is marinating meat making dressings
sauces and bacon are all crucial things
to prepare in advance of a busy service
but deep fried chicken wings a tales of
advance of their first booking that
can't be right because if you cook them
off now and leave them to cool when the
order comes in it's just a matter of
picking out how many we need and they go
back in and they come back up so nice
I'm gonna go try no I'm beginning to
suspect the good old home cooking isn't
as wholesome as it could be most of it's
coming from the freezer rather than the
salt
how many freezers we got 13 me by the
time Brian turns up there's not much
left for him to do so you can't really
feel like you're head chef if you've got
Sherita in the kitchen every morning
cooking the food and you come in to say
you send it in a sense you're not
actually really cooking you're just
coming in and putting things together
have you lost motivation yes
so if sherita's head chest gone off the
boil I'm hoping her remaining crew
part-timers have a bit more spunk
heading up front of houses Lauren she
arrives 10 minutes late for the evening
service 20 year old ad seems to be more
committed to a glamorous day job so I
panel beater kitchen porter gavin lives
next door but he appears to turn up when
he feels like it
and sherita's librarian husband Phil
hotfoot sit back from the day job to
become basement barman and DJ these are
numerous other part-time staff are all
members of Mamma Sherry's big laid-back
family so when he's in the shed I'm in
the service he slowed them down like
[ __ ] Michael Jackson I hate to ruin a
good party but if you want to run a
successful business then the terms
laid-back and professional just don't
mix it's not just about how good the
food tastes it's about how it [ __ ]
gets there as well and that is crucial